after Vladimir Putin made drastic
changes to Russia's Constitution
everyone who works under him resigned
yeah yeah when he heard about it Trump
said wait I have to resign he's probably
relieved I know oh thank god yeah sicken
him tell me what to do yesterday
speaking a trunk yesterday president
Trump was photographed wearing reading
glasses for the first time reading
glasses yeah yeah and for the first time
in history classes did not make the
person wearing them look smarter put
glasses on a turtle and it looks smarter
you all watch the debate last night okay
none of you here we go during the debate
last night Elizabeth Warren told a mom
in the audience how important the issue
of childcare is to her yeah yeah very
nice moment yeah to prove her point
Warren began nursing Pete Buddha judge
now I wish I'd want I know it was cool
one of the original cast members of
Grey's Anatomy announced he's leaving
the show yeah he said I made the painful
decision to leave Grey's Anatomy after I
realized it was still on the air
[Applause]